And I would say that one of the things
that drives the collectivist ethos,
which is often formulated in terms
of compassion for the oppressed,
which is something we'll talk
about a little bit later,
is actually a deep desire to at all costs,
avoid that responsibility.
And it's no wonder because the
responsibility is overwhelming.
Say The world fundamentally
is a tragic place,
right?
It's a place in which each of us is
broken and it's contaminated by the ever
present reality of betrayal
and malevolence and to
shoulder the responsibility
first for even admitting to that.
And second for assuming
that you are duty bound,
let's say,
to do something about that.
Well,
that's a task that anyone who has his
or her eyes open should be leery of
accepting.
And I would say,
well,
perhaps there's no credible reason for
accepting it except that every other
alternative is worse.
Okay?
And so that's a brutal fact.
So the antidote to
collectivism is individualism,
but it's not the individualism of
the privileged person with rights.
It's the terrible burden of the individual
who determines that he or she will
shoulder their
responsibility to that most.
So I developed that
idea in maps of meaning
that,
and I made a lot of
lectures about that book,
many of which are on Youtube,
some of which have become widely viewed,
I would say by a hundreds
of thousands of people now.
And so that and that course always had
a dramatic effect on my students and
their most typical comment.
There's two classes of typical comments.
Okay.
That I got from students about
my maps of meaning courses,
isn't it?
It's the same comments that I get from
people now when they come and talk to me
about my lectures.
The first comment is,
and this is about maybe
a quarter of the people,
is that
watching the lectures
are taking the course,
enabled them to put words
to things they knew,
they knew but didn't know how to say.
And so,
and that's fine because that was an ex
that was actually an explicit purpose of
the writing and the course.
And the second is that it helped
people straightened out their lives.
And that's also not that surprising to
me because a lot of what I integrated
into that book and the lectures and then
the lectures were also associated with
my personality course were ideas from
the great clinical psychologists and
psychiatrists of the 20th century.
It was a dozen of them or so,
or maybe 20 who were all
outstanding geniuses,
have slightly different types who learned
all sorts of things about how people
could put them self together
properly as individuals.
And if you learn about those things,
they're actually really helpful.
That's not surprising because they
sit at the core of an entire domain of
science and art,
let's say,
devoted to improving
people's individual lives.
I wove the responsibility idea into 12
rules cause that's really what it is.
In some sense.
It's a call to the voluntary adoption
of maximal individual responsibility and
it's a psychological work,
not a political work.
Now I think the reason that it's
attracted so much political attention,
let's say some of which gun lager
referred to in the introduction is,
well,
there's two reasons.
One is because I took what might be
regarded as a political stance about some
compelled speech legislation in Canada.
I never regarded that as a political
move because I regarded the legislation
itself as something that
wasn't a political move.
I regarded it as an attempt
by the politicians to jump
outside their domain of
acceptable conduct into the philosophical
or even the theological realm because
you don't mess with the idea of
free speech in a Western country.
And there's very sophisticated
reasons for that.
And it doesn't matter what
your reasons for doing it are.
You don't go there.
And so,
but it happened to be the more radical
leftists that were pushing this forward.
And because I objected to it,
then it was in their interest to assume
that I must be the worst sort of right
wing.
Um,
die hard I suppose,
because otherwise they'd have to
contend with my actual arguments.
And so it's simpler just to shoot the
messenger than to contend with the
arguments.
And you know,
if you stand up and say there's something
wrong in a place like Canada where
most things aren't wrong,
then it's reasonable also for people
to assume there must be something wrong
with you because most of the time there
isn't anything wrong with the country
and so a certain amount of testing is
a reasonable thing for people to do.
I guess the other element of this
that's political in some sense though,
is that within the collectivist viewpoint,
this is something that's very
interesting with regard to free speech.
I didn't really figure this out
until a couple of weeks ago.
Although the radical leftists,
and you see this particularly
in the United States now,
although the Americans have a very
strong tradition of free speech,
the radical leftists are
opposed to freedom of speech,
but that's not really right.
It's not the way to think about it.
In the radical leftist
collectivist view of the world,
there's actually no such
thing as free speech.
It said worst then,
then opposing it because the collectivists
believe that you're nothing but an
Avatar of your group.
First of all,
there is no you.
You're defined by your group membership.
And then the world is a landscape of
groups each vying for predominance.
And that's what there is.
And it's,
and so when you say that
you're speaking your mind,
that isn't something that you can
do from the collectivist viewpoint.
What you're doing is acting as an
unconscious Avatar of the power demands of
your group.
There's no you,
there was no free speech.
There's no your opinion.
There's no facts for that matter.
Everything is to be viewed in relationship
to the power struggle between groups
that even in principle cannot communicate.
And so the other reason that I detest,
let's say the collectivist viewpoint is
because I see that it leads nowhere but
to conflict.
Because if people cannot speak
as individuals between groups,
then all they can do is submit or fight.
Those are the options,
right?
Negotiation,
capitulation or warfare.
Those are the options.
And the only
process that allows for negotiation in
the absence of capitulation or conflict
is speech.
Because we can talk over our differences
and that discussion is going to be
contentious because we
actually have differences.
But compared to the contentiousness
of not talking over the differences,
it's a walk in the park.
You know,
I saw something quite remarkable that
when I was in London a month and a half
ago,
I was on this political show and one of
the things they did in this section that
didn't have anything to do with me
was to show a bunch of clips from the,
the,
there's a question period that the British
have evolved where the opposition can
go after the prime minister.
And the woman that was appearing with
me on the show had written a book about
that called Punch and Judy,
if I remember correctly,
and they showed a bunch of
clips of English mps attacking
the prime minister and
the prime minister's response all
the way from Thatcher forward.
It was absolutely vicious in the way that,
well educated British
people can be vicious,
which is very impressive
form of viciousness.
Um,
Eh,
it was no holds barred verbal combat.
And you might think,
well,
isn't that horrible?
Because it's certainly rife,
let's say with micro aggressions,
but it's not horrible because none of
them had their hands around each other's
necks,
right?
It was all civilized.
It was everyone was standing where they
were supposed to stand and they were
hurling invective and making criticisms
and making accusations and defending
themselves and all of that.
But it was all contained within
the peaceful confines of this,
of the house of parliament.
And that's our miracle,
really.
It's a miracle.
And the British are
particularly good at that.
And so you leave free speech alone
because the alternative to free speeches,
capitulation or conflict,
and unless you want one of those or both,
and you might,
then you don't interfere with the
mechanism that enables people's people to
state the nature of their reality and
to clarify that and to negotiate with
others,
even though that negotiation is
painful and emotionally demanding and
threatening and anxiety provoking and
aggression instigating and all of those
things,
because the alternative is far worse.